j'aimais chez on est de retour dans
l'ohl en direct il ya un décor de ski
puisque on a fait les vacances de
février les vacances d'hiver
on va donc me faire le trou numéro 4
pour voir si c'est le trou chocolatées
ou si c'est le trou avec avalanche
tonneau quel niveau n'obéissez pas gagné
à nice 2 1 je veux pas faire peur à tout
le monde mais si on fait tout ça super
et fort on va y arriver à ça alors je
vous dis je vous préviens juste anne
il est nerveux fabrice di vizio j'allais
déjà pratiqué bien il ya il ya deux
problèmes comme toujours
1 est ce que vous vous rendez compte du
poids des mots le relâchement des
français bon qu'est ce que c'est que
cette façon poser les questions les
français ceux relatifs aux arts les
français sont des enfants est
effectivement qui jusqu'ici étaient des
enfants sages
et maintenant il se relâche alors si on
pouvait commencer par intelsat en tunise
est allé dans la rue quand il fait beau
c'est pas un relâchement c'est normal
dix mois de mars on a conçu les deux
pays
ça c'est bon ça vous commandez le
réalisateur du film à 30 mille morts
déjà dit mais mise à part ça veut dire
quoi de roanne pour finir il semble que
maintenant monsieur nous ça veut dire
quoi d'autre ça veut dire quoi d'autre
tu as posé au plateau bien rodé c'est
dire comme il savait pas d'âme
parler tous les jours aux abords des
grandes premières vivait dans une grotte
dont vous ne saurez jamais ce que je
vais vous donner un conseil
et je vous assure que ça conseils
pertinents quand vous n'êtes pas en
plateau essayer de regarder les études
qu'ils ont publiées
vous apprendrez beaucoup de choses et ça
vous à ça vous donne un avantage c'est
un peu moins idiot sur les plateaux pas
en fait lohan a été raccompagné à son
hôtel par son chauffeur ce canal
chauffeur à disposition à les entourer
un sur ce tournage évidemment on la
laisse pas seul malheureusement la nuit
elle est dans sa chambre et ce matin
guillaume garnier qui est notre
rédacteur en chef a retrouvé loana dans
un état lamentable dans sa chambre avec
la chambre sans dessus dessous les
poubelles qui ont été fouillés
donc elle a été emmenée aux urgences à 9
heures du matin elle est à l'hôpital
d'hyères
elle était dans un état très grave mais
elle peut encore elle peut encore parler
et elle va être transférée en hôpital
psychiatrique
ce qu'on a vu sur le tournage c'est
qu'elle était tout le temps avec une
bouteille d'un d'une célèbre boisson et
on s'est rendu compte que dès qu'elle
n'en buvaient en fait elle changé d'état
et et elle aurait une boisson alcoolisée
une brassée de l'oasis
voilà une boisson voilà elle aurait mis
dans cette bouteille du gic non mais non
mais l'abus de mélanger à huy mélangé
avec du ghb liquide alors trois mois
après les faits déjà comment tu vas me
michel mas disons que mon état fluctue
je vois que tu es toujours un truc qu au
bras comment ça c'est sûr c'est une
attelle
comme j'ai eu le tendon sectionné on a
ressoudé avec une encre où on a sauvé
mon biceps du coup et après base et j'ai
forcément une rééducation affaire est
dans la tête comment ça va c'est moi et
au corps s'est remis plus vite que la
tête je crois dans la tête tu es comment
c'est toujours compliqué mais on on fait
en sorte comme s'ils avaient voulu
laisser quoi que tu te reste traumatisée
et à des voitures penses tu arrives à
dormir normalement tu arrives à jamais
c'est vraiment un match que je j'ai un
peu de mal mais je crois que quoi qu
est-ce qui est ce qui est bien dans la
nuit qui est apte et halte à l'angoissé
ce jeu c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je
me fais suivre là dessus mais du tfc
après l'agression tu as décidé de te
faire suivre pour pour essayer de voilà
de surmonter dès que j'ai compris que
tout seul ça risque d'être compliqué
reproche clairement je vais vous dire
clairement ce qu'on va voir dans les
rôles de fournir la cam à des
personnalités notamment d'en fournir à
loana il se trouve que ludovic et j'ai
là et je connais bien la version puisque
on me l'a racontée est mort d'une
overdose
mais bon peu importe
moi je vous dis moi je vous dis je vous
n'avez pas vous n'avez pas une image
vous n'avez pas une image excusez-moi de
vous démettre est bien léger mode la
grand-font désolé mais vous et moi je
vais je pense que j'ai fait moins de mal
autour de moi
il faut parler franchement aujourd'hui
le gros problème de loana je me perds
mon rôle c est la dc c'est la dernière
mais c'est la came c'est la droite
moi j'ai eu un texto de loi n'a
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous allez
voir si c'est ton ami nul ouanna moi
c'est ma petite soeur tu vois moi c'est
ma petite sur l'aude et on a eu très
peur pour le web très peur j'ai appelé
c'est moi même qui ai appelé le sait mal
tourner sur loire les caves et dans les
médias qu'ils annonçaient qu'elle est
entre la vie et la mort moi ça fait deux
jours que je dors pas tu comprends oui
et la loi nome a envoyé encore désolé
pour hier sylvie m'a donné un peu trop
de médicaments parce que j'étais stressé
et du coup j'ai mal supporté non ça là
je lui ai donné la veille à nax oui je
sais j'ai le même message ces attentions
alors elle est très fragile on l'a calmé
qui lui a donné sa toute façon c'est une
thune quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas
détecter à l'aéroport doute qu'il eut
d'autres aspects
elle peut le commander sur internet est
partout sur internet où le discernement
pour faire ça en ce moment de commander
cela ne porterait pas le chapeau tu
n'auras pas le chapeau je débuterai très
en colère hier hier soir c'était partagé
entre la peine d la colère et je me
rends compte que même après avoir fait
cette vidéo la colère elle elle
redescend pas ce que j'ai reçu
énormément de messages après la vidéo
d'étudiants de gens qui souffrent si
j'ai fait la vidéo c'est surtout parce
que mon ami me l'a demandé sinon je
l'aurais pas fait mais j'avais juste
besoin de dire au président qu'il faut
descendre de son château doré et se
rendre compte que il ya beaucoup de gens
qui souffrent et que je pas sûr que
toutes les décisions qui ont été prises
ont été faites dans le bon timing
alors elle a décidé d'être avant son
suicide mais elle écrit quoi je pas
rentrer dans le détail parce que je
pense que ça reste un petit peu dans
l'intimidation mais dans mesrine pour
les grosses way you do de danse et sur
les détails mais voilà c'est réellement
la situation actuelle la crise sanitaire
qui l'a poussé à commettre avec l'âge à
l'aller 21 ans elle faisait quoi dont
deux comme et des études de médecine et
ironie du sort elle a craqué elle a
craqué parce que parce que déjà c'est
une fille qui était pétillante
c'était une jeune fille qui qui qui
respirait la joie de vivre qui était
pétillante qui était brillance
[Musique]
moi je voulais juste qu'on arrête les
sous-entendus dégueulasse qui sous
entendent justement qu'on est là pour
faire de l'argent sur le dos de la
misère de loana c'est ce qui se dit
aussi voilà bien sûr que je dirais qu'on
a ça concrètement des documents perdus
en effet plaint donc on n'a pas besoin
de faire de l'argent de sueur sur la
misère de loi n'a ensuite des
documentaires on en a déjà préparé plein
on a déjà arrêté la production de plein
de documentaires justement pour des
raisons éthiques
et ensuite attention les deux
documentaires on les fait avec loana
qu'évidemment mois on voit en cet état
oui il ya un moment je me suis posé la
question mais qu'est ce qui me ferait
arrêter de faire ces documentaires
qu'est ce qui nous ferait arrêter c'est
loana
on est tout le temps en contact avec
elle elle a envie de faire ses
documentaires ce soit à l'hôpital et à
ce moment là elle est suivie personne ne
peut l'interviewer mais faire je ne sais
quoi
soit elle est chez elle et puis recevoir
faire un reportage c'est son médicament
le problème de loana que je connais bien
c'est que elle ne peut pas vivre
autrement alors on ne peut pas vu
autrement au contraire c'est lui avais
excusez-moi de vous contredire je
comprends parfaitement qu'il faille
stopper parce que moi personnellement
2009 tf1 m'avait demandé de donner mon
avis et je leur ai dit qu'il fallait
stopper
il fallait faire un break définitif pour
remettre sa santé à jour
malheureusement le n 1 on l'a fabriqué
ne cherchez pas à confisquer la
démocratie avec moi ne cherchez pas
employer des mots dont vous ne comprenez
pas le sens jeu pendant contredire tuque
est effectivement mais n'ayons aucun
argument attendait n'ayant aucun
argument avant de poser sur les fonds à
vous de chercher les victimes en
vannerie jamais imprimé 15 pages mais
bon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la vente est bien gardé mais rien n'est
pas moi si j'ai mal et ça s'est fait au
premier vent pas je vais arriver avec
non mais vous les autres vous pourrez
tiko mais je voulais vous dire ce qu'il
se passe c'est qu'en fait ce que vous et
moi alors je vous en prie père des
enfants c'est qu'il ya un parapet il a
dû ce matelas se pencher pas très bien
puis le ton il s'est renversé parce que
s'il avait voulu se suicider
premièrement les déjà il aimait trop sa
famille et rossetti y
il aurait laissé un mot il aurait
[Musique]
peut-être laissé des signes peut-être je
sais pas alors ils m'ont démontré là
dessus sur ce mur il essaie de
s'accrocher et il est tombé en langues
trouvent les ongles il n'a pas de quoi
la tête là rien du tout puisque quand
quentin quand on a vu la maison
funéraire
on a pensé un jour ils nous l'ont laissé
à le regarder il est il magnifique
il nous parlait il y la can est calme et
tous les ans il était non moi je dire et
alors pu le sauver
moi et puis je veux savoir la vérité
comment ça s'est passé pourquoi pourquoi
se trouvait là c'est la plupart à midi
par an 9 heures du matin ou 10 heures du
matin de la maison 1 et ça arrive à deux
heures c'est pas pourquoi jean j'espère
que vous allez je sais que christophe
vous le rendra jamais cavalier moins
avoir la vérité assez vite et c'était
vraiment un honneur pour moi de vous
avoir ce soir chez nous on n'avait pas
besoin de foot
je suis français toute l'année qui est
zidane qui joue pas mais ce que je veux
que tu comprennes c'est que si tu passes
ton année qui vient parce que là c'est
top chrono dans un an et une élection
présidentielle moi je le dit et on a
déjà parlé de ça il va y avoir des
responsables si des gens dont tu t'es
séparés comme le front national arrive
au pouvoir parce que ça sera un échec
collectif
les banlieues c'est un état d'esprit
fizi pourquoi parce que je trouve que
c'est une réussite jusqu'à aujourd'hui
écoute moi je te dis la vérité à temps
mais des trois manifestations avec des
blancs en plein paris tecteo quoi tu te
qualifies m'a passé j'avais dit si tu
dois te baptiser aussi
des blancs mon sens il y avait des noms
à 30 2% règlement d'alice doit avoir
peur d'un autre genre et cécilia rené
cécilia qui oui
oh
[Musique]
garçons
et
[Musique]
mais
c'est moi c'est pas mal
vous m'emmerdez
[Musique]